Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Welcome back to Polycast.
Recently, a few of you
have left some comments
asking if I could do an episode
on the neon-animation elements.
Now, since we did an episode
previously on behaviors,
I thought now would be
a great time to dive
into the animation stuff.
So come on down to tablet
town, and let's get hacking.
So neon-animations, what
exactly are these things?
Well, neon-animations
are a collection
of behaviors and elements that
let you use Web Animations.
And if you've never heard
of Web Animations before,
it's basically a
new set of standards
that unify CSS and
JavaScript animations.
So you can write your
animation in JavaScript
and do something that's really
programmatic and awesome,
but have it run on the GPU
like it was a CSS animation.
So this lets you turn your
kind of boring sign-in form
or whatever into this crazy,
awesome, bouncy thing.
And I realize that's sort of
over the top, but whatever.
You get the point.
So today what we're
going to do is
we're going to focus
on the behaviors
in the neon-animations set.
And then in another episode,
I'm going to do a followup
and cover the elements,
like neon-animated pages.
If you're not sure
what behaviors are,
you check out this
video right here
and get caught up on behaviors
so you can learn how they work.
And then once you've
seen that, come back
and check out this video.
So the behaviors we're
going to work on today are
the neon-animation-behavior
and the
neon-animation-runner-behavior.
So the
neon-animatable-behavior--
what this does is it allows
you to add animations
to your elements.
So you can add like
a fade-in animation
or a scale-up animation, lots
of really cool stuff there.
But what this doesn't do is it
doesn't allow you to actually
play those animations.
There's no playback
built into this thing.
So for playback support,
that's when you need
the
neon-animation-runner-behavior.
So that gives us playback.
Now, what's really
cool about the
neon-animation-runner-behavior
is it actually implements this
animatable-behavior as well.
So for the elements that we're
going to be building today,
the only behavior that
we need to work with
is neon-animation-runner,
which is awesome.
Now, you might wonder, why
this does behavior exist even?
Well, neon-animatable
is going to become
more important when we go and
we look at the animated pages
elements in that
following episode.
But today, we're just going to
work on neon-animation-runner.
So the thing that
we're going to build
is this little sort of
pop-up sign-up form thing.
So you can see here I click this
Open button, it animates in.
I click the Close
button, it fades out.
Now, I realize there's already
a paper dialog element.
And if you're building a sign-in
form, you should absolutely,
100% use the paper
dialog element.
I created my own one
just as a teaching aid
because it's going
to help us really
illustrate a lot of the concepts
in the neon-animation set.
By all means, if you're actually
building a sign-in form,
go use paper dialog.
So for my element, here's
the bower.json for it.
My element is
called login-panel.
And the interesting
thing here is just
to scroll down and check
out its dependencies.
And you can see I'm
importing paper-elements 1.0
and neon-elements 1.0.
And I'm often pretty lazy.
I'll import like the entire
paper- and neon-element sets
when I'm developing because
from my perspective,
it doesn't really matter
if you pull all these sets
into your development
environment.
Your file size, what you
actually ship into production,
is only what you import and
only what you vulcanize.
So I'm often lazy.
I'll pull in the full
sets just so I can
have an easier time developing.
Now, inside of my editor,
this is the definition
for my login-panel element.
You can see that we've
got some styles here.
The one to note is that
on the host element,
we've set display
none by default,
so you just can't see
the thing initially.
And then scrolling around,
you can see the templates.
Pretty vanilla Polymer.
We've got paper-material
element, which
is going to give
us a little card,
and we've got some paper-inputs
for the sign-in form.
And further down, you've
got the actual definition
for the element down
here in JavaScript,
so pretty typical stuff.
I've called it login-panel.
It's got one property right
now, this opened Boolean,
and then I've got these
two methods, show and hide.
What these are going to do is
just change the display style
from inline-block
to none depending
on if it's showing or hiding.
So right now if you
just call these methods,
the element's just going
to, like, blink on screen
and then disappear
really, really quickly.
But I want this thing
to animate, right?
I want it to add
a little pizzazz.
So to do that, I'll go back
up to the top of the element
and I'm going to add
imports for some animations.
Now, the cool thing is
the neon-animations set
actually comes with a
few prefab animations
that you can just drop in.
So I'm going to pull in
a scale-up animation,
a fade-out animation,
and then I'm
also going to pull in that
animation-runner-behavior.
So check out these file
paths right here just
because I want you see this.
So everything's coming from
the neon-animation package,
and then I've got this
animations directory.
This is where the prefab
animations hang out.
And then also in
neon-animation package,
I'm just pulling
in that behavior.
So we're all set up there.
Now I'm ready to scroll down
and I can add the behavior
to my elements definitions.
So in my behaviors
array, I'll add
neon-animation-runner-behavior.
And what that's
going to do is it's
going to give me access to
this animationConfig property.
So remember, the way
that behaviors work
is they mix in properties and
methods into your elements.
So by adding that
behavior, I now
have access to this really
cool animationConfig thing.
And this is where
I can set up all
of the animations on my element.
So to do this, I'm going
to return an object,
and every key inside
of this object
is going to be the name of an
animation that I want to run.
So I'm going to create
one called entry.
And the values for this
entry object, the name,
is going to be the name of the
animation it should execute,
which is that scale-up
animation that we imported.
And then the node, this is
the target of the animation.
So in this case,
we're saying, I want
this element to animate itself.
So I'm just passing this.
But if there were
children inside of here
that you wanted to animate,
you could use something
like Polymer's
automatic node finding.
You could be like,
I want this .$.
some child to be the target.
I want that thing
to animate instead.
But in this case, we're just
saying, hey, animate myself
with this entry animation.
And then we can also
create an exit animation.
So this time I'm
going to call fade-out
for that exit animation.
And then I'm going to go
down here into the show
and hide methods and add
two calls to play animation.
So remember, I said the
animatable-behavior, that's
what lets us actually add
animations to an element.
And then the
animation-runner-behavior,
that's what gives
us playback support.
So that's where these
methods come from.
And again, we're just
calling the named animations
that we just created up there.
One thing that you might
notice if you're astute
and you're sort of
paying attention
here is that right here
inside of hide, we're
setting display to none before
we execute the animation.
So that means that this thing
would just blink off screen
and we would never see it.
So we can take this out.
We can actually remove
that line there.
I'll remove it with
a little comment.
But we're going to need to
revisit this in just a bit,
and I'll show you why.
But first, let's
preview our element.
So over here when I
click this Open button,
it's going to call
that show method.
When I click this
Close button, it's
going to call the hide method.
So I click Open, animates
in with scale-up.
Then I click Close, and
watch what's going to happen.
It fades out, but then it
sort of pops back to the state
it was in before.
So what's going on there?
Well, Web Animations
don't actually
preserve changes that you make
to the state of your elements.
So if you're changing the
CSS properties or something
like that, there's
no preservation.
At first I was like,
well, that sort of sucks.
I kind of wish it did
preserve those changes.
But then I realized that
would be potentially very
difficult to debug.
If you had a complex
animation that
was applying lots of styles
and properties to an element,
it'd be very hard later
to figure out, like,
when did that thing change
its size or whatever.
So Web Animation says, hey,
that's going to be up to you.
You're going to need to preserve
whatever state changes you do.
And you can do that
by adding a class
or just manipulating the style
property like we were doing.
So how do we do that?
Well, back in our
elements definition,
I'm going to add a
listeners object.
And if you've never worked with
the listeners object before,
it's really useful.
Now, this is something that
all Polymer elements get.
And the listeners
object is basically
shorthand for AddEventListener.
So we're going to
say, hey, I want
to create a listener for the
NeonAnimationFinish event.
And I want it to call this
onNeonAnimationFinish method,
which I'm going to
define down here below.
So when the element is done
animating, call this method.
And inside of this
method, we're going
to check to see if
it's opened or not.
And if it's not open, we'll
tell it to display none.
So now we can go back and we
can check our animation out.
So click the Open button, and
it animates as it was before.
And now when I click Close,
that state gets preserved.
Awesome.
So what if you want to
add multiple animations
to your element that all kind
of play at the same time?
Well, that's actually
really easy to do,
and I can show you how
to do it over here.
But first, let's import a few
more animations to work with.
So I'm going to pull
in a fade-in animation,
and I'm also going to pull
in one called slide-down.
And down in my animationConfig
object, instead
of just having a single
entry object here,
I can actually have an array.
So I can have an array
of animation objects
that I would like to play.
You can see here that I've set
the first one, the animation
name, to
slide-down-animation, and then
the second one,
fade-in-animation.
And these two animations are
going to play in parallel.
So they're both going to be
happening at the same time.
So let's go preview
that over in Chrome just
to see what that does.
So I'm going to click
the Open button,
and you'll see it sort of
slides down and animates
at the same time.
So it fades in and slides
down both at the same time.
Cool, but what if you
wanted to sort of change
the timing of that?
Maybe you want your animations
to play sequentially
or you want them to
be offset slightly.
Well, that's really
easy to do as well.
So every animation object
also has an optional timing
object that you can give it.
And the timing object
has a few properties
that you can work with.
You could set duration.
So I'm going to say that the
slide-down-animation animation
should have a duration of 2,000
milliseconds, so two seconds.
And my fade-in
animation should have
a duration of 1,000, so one
second, and a delay of 1,000.
So it's going to wait one
second before it starts playing,
and then it's going to
only be a second long,
so it'll end at the same time
as the slide-down-animation.
And you can use delay to
have your animations play
kind of like one
right after the other.
Or if you want things
to be sort of offset,
just kind of on
top of one another,
you can do that as well.
And what this is going
to do is it's really
going to change the
feel of this animation.
So watch this and
kind of compare it
to what we were doing before.
Now when I click
Open, it's a much more
gradual, kind of
smoother transition
that we see there
because it doesn't even
start fading in until
it's about halfway
through the
slide-down-animation.
So just by changing
those little properties,
we were able to really alter the
feel of that animation, which
is pretty cool.
Now, how would you go about
writing your own animation?
Because it might
seem really daunting,
but it's actually super easy.
And what I usually do is I look
at one of the animations that's
already in the
prefab animation set,
and then I'll use that
as a starting point.
So this is the definition
for the fade-in animation.
And if we scroll
around here, you
can see that it looks a lot
like any other Polymer element.
There's some documentation for
the options that it supports.
And we go down and we
look at its definition,
and you can see that
it's just got an
is property here for its name.
It implements this
NeonAnimationBehavior.
We haven't talked
about that yet,
but that's the behavior you
need to implement if you're
creating your own animation.
And then it has this
config function.
And this is really the
meat of the animation here,
and it's really
not that complex.
You can see that the
node that it's targeting
is whatever node we passed
in in our configuration.
And then it creates what's
called a KeyframeEffect.
And this right here, this is
the Web Animations API at work.
So we're creating a
KeyframeEffect Object.
We're telling it
which node to target,
and then we pass it this
array of key frames that
are written out in JavaScript.
And here we're just saying
we want it to go from 0 to 1
in terms of opacity, and we
also pass in the timing stuff.
So this is pretty easy.
You could quickly see
how you could just kind
of mimic this and implement
your own animation,
and that's exactly what I did.
I created a bounce-in animation.
So we're going to create
kind of a bouncing effect.
And I took that
scale-up animation
we were working with before.
I just copied it and
pasted it in here.
You can see that it's got pretty
similar options to the thing we
were just working with.
Really, the only difference
is this transformOrigin
configuration thing
here, which just
lets us set the origin
point we'll be scaling from.
But then everything
else is the same.
And what I did was I added
all these different key frames
along the way.
So start at scale 0,
work up to scale 1,
and then here are the key
frames sort of interstitially
for getting too big and too
small and too big and too small
until you have what looks like
kind of a cool bouncing effect.
So really, this is
all there is to it.
And if you want, you can also,
I believe, mix in other things
here.
So you could have transform and
opacity and a few other things
running at the same time.
But what this gives
us is the ability
to go over to our
animationConfig object.
We can replace our
entry animation
with that bounce-in
animation, and then we
can import its definition.
And with that in
place, we're all good.
We can just go and
click the Open button.
And now you'll see
we get this kind
of frantic bounce-in effect,
which is a little crazy.
So we go back.
We add some timing
to this thing,
we stretch out the
duration a little bit.
And now when we play it, it's a
much more digestible animation.
It's a little bit smoother.
Right now, these key
frames that I showed you,
these are all being
evenly distributed
across the life cycle or the
duration of that animation.
So they all take the
exact same amount
of time, which is not
really how animation works.
Oftentimes, you want
some parts to be longer
and some parts to be shorter.
And so if you want to do
that, it's also very easy.
You can just add offsets to
your key frame animations,
and so you can see here
that I'm offsetting from 0
and we're going to go
all the way up to 1.
So you can think about this
at like 0% of your animation
duration to 100% of
your animation duration.
And this is the amount
of time that should go on
between each of these.
So from 0 to basically
80% through the lifespan
of the animation,
I want to spend
all that time just
scaling up to 1.5, just
doing this initial sort
of key frame tween here.
And then I want the
other 20% of my animation
to just be occurring with the
bouncing bits at the very end.
So it'll be a long
scale-up and then
it'll bounce really, really
fast all at the end there.
So if we go and we
preview this, you'll
see now that it's
a longer scale-up
and we get more of
that bounce at the end.
So pretty cool.
Pretty easy way to
really dial in the look
and feel your animation so
you get exactly what you want.
The last thing I
want to mention--
as I was recording this,
I came across a little bug
in the animation
system, so watch here.
I'm going to click
the Open button.
I'm going to play my animation.
And then I'm going to
click this Close button
and I'm going to click
the Close button twice.
And now when I click Open again,
I no longer see my animation.
So what's up there?
Well, there seems to be a bug
where if your animations stack,
it can break, which
means it is time
to bust out our old friend
(DEEP VOICE) The Sweet Hacks.
It's been a little
while since we saw them,
but now they're back.
What I'm going to do
is in my handlers,
I'm going to add a call to
this CancelAnimation method.
So when I call
CancelAnimation, it just
throws out what other
animation was already playing.
And now when I click
Open, it bounces.
I double-click Close, it closes.
I click Open, and
it works again.
We're back on track.
So I realize it's kind
of an annoying bug,
but I wanted to include
that little pro tip for you
in case anyone else
runs into that issue.
All right.
Wow, we covered a
ton of stuff today.
And I've got to admit,
when I started this,
I didn't actually know a lot
about the animation system.
So it's been really
cool for me to learn,
and I hope you all
enjoyed it as well.
Now, I'm going to do a followup
episode on the animated pages
element.
So click that little Subscribe
button so you don't miss that.
As always, thank you
so much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.
Hey, there,
Polycasters, Rob here.
Q&A time.
Alex Shaw writes
in and asks, "What
is one quick tip
you'd give someone
who's moving from Polymer
0.5 to Polymer 1.0?"
So good question, Alex.
Recently, one of the
members of the Polymer team
wrote this really, really
cool module called polyup.
And it will actually take
your old Polymer 0.5 code
and do crazy machinations to it
and spit out Polymer 1.0 code.
It is really awesome.
So you can follow
this link right here
to check out the polyup website.
There's a little repl where
you can drop your code in
and it'll just
automatically convert it.
And there's also an
MPM module that you
can install and just sort of run
it from your command line, so
really cool stuff there.
Again, thank you, Alex,
for sending in a question.
We'll have our minions
reach out to you
and send you a swag pack.
If you have questions, be
sure to leave them down
in the comments, and we
just might feature you
on a future episode of Polycast.
So thank you all so
much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.